North Jersey I think Eli Manning is
killing the giant season
Lil Wayne got money so Dale said I'm a
murderer well that's just our
relationship you know
I mean it's not like you can draft QB
over saquan yeah I think they probably
should have look I love the fans I would
never harm a fan but do I think they
protect Eli yeah well how many reasons
y'all giving us Eli won two Super Bowls
against us so now they're stuck with him
forever rumors are there's tension if
like can you passport to your best
receiver no we must only check down no
comment no comment but yes I am loving
this but get over here you won't believe
what Gruden did now yeah we don't even
need to be good to win this division
anymore look I barely killed the Giants
I'm not capable coach I'm here to bail
you out again okay sorry I have to have
my family yell to Mars goodbye what the
hell did I do ruin the Giants of course
[Music]
subscribe to this Channel and rot your
brain with more episodes YouTube It's a
distraction coach coach coach wait coach
coach hey wait coach coach